how can nintendo make animal crossing
new horizons even better
in today's video i'll offer up some
suggestions on how nintendo can take an
already fantastic game and make it even
better
people of the internet retro racking
tour here and welcome back to another
animal crossing new horizons video
if we're meeting for the first time i'm
just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos twice a week here on
youtube and today is all about making
animal crossing
even better than it already is here are
five quality of life changes i'd love to
see nintendo try and implement within
the next few months
of course i want to hear from you guys
as well so let me know what other ideas
you have
in the comments below number one buying
in bulk
okay we might as well start with an
obvious one here right why don't we have
the ability to buy in bulk on
any item sure buying in bulk is in the
game currently but only for specific
items and only in amounts preset by
nintendo
flowers and tree saplings for example
can be purchased as a pack of one
or five but why not let us buy 20 or
7 all at once turnips of course are
completely separate items sold by a
different vendor those are sold in
bundles of 10.
but again why not open this up and allow
players to purchase items in any amount
provided they have room of course
if i want to stock up on fishing poles
then let me buy 10 all at once rather
than having me place 10 separate orders
with tommy and timmy of course you could
also apply this to the shopping app
which you unlock on your phone later in
the game or even the kiosk that is in
resident services throughout the game
number two more visibility for item sets
at the heart of animal crossing
is a game all about collecting
personally i'm way more inclined to
chase after an item when i see that i'm
missing part of a set
so why not give us a little sneak peek
at some of the items we're missing out
on
let's say you craft or find a furniture
item that's part of a larger set
what if at that point you could then
look through your recipe book to see the
recipes in the set that you still lack
or if the item is only available to buy
show us the other items that we can
purchase from that particular set
they could even take this a step further
and let us know all the possible ways
that we can go about obtaining the item
at least for me this would be a pretty
powerful way to encourage me to hunt and
search for even more
items and thus increase replayability
and yes i know you can view these items
online but the vast majority of animal
crossing players most likely stick to
the in-game tools available
number three daily story lines so one of
the biggest critiques of animal crossing
is how quickly you can burn out doing
the same tasks over and over again
and while i don't expect animal crossing
to ever offer some insane branching
narrative
nor do i believe it should i do think
there are ways nintendo could weave a
bit more story into the game to help
keep things fresh and interesting
my idea is something i'm calling daily
story lines
the concept here is that each day would
have a randomized storyline involving
one or several of your villagers
now this could be fairly simple and
straightforward but still staying within
the current confines of the game let's
say octavian decides to host a party one
evening and needs your help getting
ready for it
as part of this storyline you'd be
tasked with inviting other villagers
designing a special decoration
helping set up for the party by
arranging furniture and maybe even
catching a few fish for the dinner
those are just a few of the basic ideas
i have but i think you get the idea
of course nintendo could sweeten the pot
even further by offering a reward at the
end
maybe you could even choose between
three different rewards upon completing
the final section of the storyline am i
asking for too much
i don't think i'm asking for too much
moving on to number four
crafting multiples of the same item how
many times have you
sighed while spamming away on the a
button waiting for your items to finish
crafting i'm looking at you manila clams
this is one of those small changes that
would really make a huge difference in
our day-to-day enjoyment of the game
if you have enough materials the game
should allow you to craft as many as you
want
all at once i'd even be fine with the
actual crafting process taking a few
seconds longer if you're crafting
multiples of an item
but the process of having to go into the
menu and select your item each time
grows tedious and boring rather quickly
and just to be clear here i'm only
talking about when you want to craft
multiple copies of the same
item so you'd still need to go into the
craft menu each time you wanted to craft
a different item
number five terraforming improvements
terraforming is the best addition to an
animal crossing game
in years maybe ever yeah i said it
having the ability to reshape your
island make your own cliffs and alter
your waterways
offers an incredible amount of
replayability and flexibility for making
your island exactly as you want
and of course we want even more sorry
nintendo it's all out of love
as wonderful as terraforming is it's
incredibly
time consuming there's no way to make
large scale changes
you'll need to make any modifications
tile by tile
by tile that's right one tile at a time
you're also pretty severely limited with
your bridges and inclines
you can have eight of each but it's not
the number of them that's so much of a
problem it's the fact that it takes an
entire day to add or remove one of them
but let's ignore the problems with
bridges and inclines
and just focus on terraforming for a
moment if nintendo could figure out a
way to let you make
large scale changes rather than going
tile by tile
it would be a huge win maybe they even
start small by letting us alter 1
4 or 16 tiles at a time so at least with
that setting you could create a large
cliff or waterway
much faster than going one tile at a
time
another idea that would save creators
time is to offer a dedicated button for
the two types of edges on your cliffs
and rivers
as it is now you have to press the
button twice at just the right angle to
shape the edges how you want them
better yet give us even more edging
options if you'd like to see any of
these ideas implemented into new
horizons give me a thumbs up on the
video here and don't forget to comment
down below
letting me know what other ideas you
have thank you so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon